so the irony in these
systems
is that the irony in predictive systems
is that they're actually unpredictable
at least at first when machine learning
systems are new they're often inaccurate
which is actually not what we expect
from our things you know 60 or 70
accuracy is actually really good for a
first pass of a machine learning system
but even 90 accuracy isn't enough to
make a prediction a predictive system
feel right because it's making decisions
all the time you know it's gonna be
making mistakes all the time
it's fine if your house is a couple of
degrees cooler than you'd like or warmer
or whatever
but if your wheelchair refuses to go to
a drinking fountain that's next to a
door because it's been trained on doors
and it can't tell what you're saying is
i want to go to that thing next to the
door not to the door that's a real
problem
you know for and for all the times the
system gets things right you judge it on
its mistakes
and mistakes create anxiety and anxiety
is an incredibly heavy kind of cognitive
load to bear
and a little doubt about whether a
supposedly smart system is going to do
the right thing is enough to turn a user
experience that's right most of the time
into one that's more trouble than it's
worth
the last issue comes as a result of
these previous two control how do we
maintain some level of control over
these devices when their behavior is by
definition statistical and unpredictable
on the one hand you know you can mangle
your device's predictive behavior by
giving it too much data
one i visited nest one time in their in
their early days and they told me that
none of the nests in their office
actually worked because they were
constantly fiddling with them they're
kind of they're constantly like playing
around
and in machine learning this is what's
called over training
on the other hand
um
if i have no direct way to control it
other than through my own behavior how
do i adjust it you know so amazon and
netflix's recommendation systems which
are machine learning systems for
predicting what you might like they've
been around for a long time
they give you some context about why
they recommend recommended something why
they're doing something
but what if my only interface is a
garden hose
what do i do
how do i get it to stop spraying water
as interesting as these issues are i
actually think that most importantly
what they represent is that we're
entering into a new relationship with
our device ecosystem
we're experiencing a sea change in our
relationship to the built world so think
of a sewing machine it's really complex
but it basically acts in response to us
computers acting autonomously
erode this simple tool user relationship
at the dawn of computing in the late
1940s cyberneticists like norma weiner
norbert weiner philosophized about this
increasingly complex relationship
between people and computers and how it
was fundamentally different than the way
that we've interacted with other kinds
of machines and other kinds of tools
so developers who are working in
supervisory control of machine of
manufacturing machines so basically you
know uh things that build cars things
that are the you know giant robots and
factories they've actually they've been
having to deal with this with these
questions very pragmatically for a very
long time
um
now thanks to the internet of things
it's actually everybody's problem so
this
this is a diagram by the by the great
tom sheridan who was a brilliant
brilliant engineer and bill over plank
this is from 1978
in which what they're trying to do is
they're trying to illustrate four ways
that semi-autonomous computers and
humans can work together to solve a
problem this actually comes out of an
amazing project when they were in the
freaking 70s they were doing these like
semi-autonomous submersible robots that
would like go deep underwater and
they were so deep underwater
that you'd have to control them from the
surface but you didn't have like really
great control you just have to tell them
what to do and they'd have like 1975
they were doing this
sheridan continued to think about this
because
he's a smart guy
by 2000 he'd actually expanded that idea
to create this framework and to define a
spectrum of responsibility between
people and computers so it ranges from
the top number one um so i'll read it
for the folks in back uh the the
computer offers no assistance humans
must make all decisions and actions um
so it ranges from one where humans do
all the work that's like you know you
writing an essay uh unless you are in
school in which case you google for it
or
you knitting
to uh uh 10 computers doing all the work
the computer decides everything and acts
autonomously ignoring the human
that
is your car's fuel injection controller
so um of course the goal
is to get
you know something now
down here near nine or ten um and that's
kind of the maximum reduction in
cognitive load but for a system to
qualify for that it needs to be very
stable its effects its effects need to
be very predictable
and more importantly its role needs to
be very well embedded and understood in
society we trust it to do that thing
at the airport we trust the monorail
computer to work without a without human
intervention but we don't trust the
plane autopilot to do that
even though as i understand it planes
can basically fly themselves these days
it's not socially embedded yet
predictive iot devices
generally fall between five and seven
today and probably for the near future
the problem is is that this is the exact
range where you're maximizing someone's
cognitive load because you're making
them make a lot of decisions but not
necessarily doing all the work for them
so the result of the automation had
really better be worth it in order for
that system to work
moreover that relationship fundamentally
undermines what we expect from our tools
because when that tool is trying to
anticipate what
we're trying to do and try to get in
front of us and doing it
it fundamentally changes our working
relationship with
[Music]
it you